a 10-year sentence for a henderson woman
convicted of distributing fentanyl was
reduced to two years
according to court records it was a
compassionate release because of covet
19.
so the woman sold fake drugs to a friend
that resulted in a drug
overdose and the victim's mother calling
for justice
the i-team's vanessa murphy here live in
studio with the story vanessa
what is compassionate release brian so
compassionate release is used when
issues like illness or certain family
circumstances are considered and a
prisoner is released early and
doesn't have to serve their original
full sentence
over the past year according to the u.s
attorney's office
200 inmates from cases in nevada have
made this request
since the start of the pandemic and the
court has granted about
40. this mother asks where's the
compassion for the victims
and their families she was my one and
only daughter
my only child my daughter made a bad
decision my daughter was
not what she died at yvonne kerner says
in 2015 her daughter christiana moved
from ohio to las vegas for a new
beginning
in 2017 the 25 year old woman died of a
drug overdose
got you know obviously wrapped up in
partying and stuff and
met somebody who you know portrayed
herself as somebody she could trust
and would sell her drugs investigators
say tiana cordova
knowingly sold kerner fake pills with
fentanyl
a powerful synthetic opioid kerner
thought she was buying percocet
cordova was arrested and charged in 2018
by federal authorities
according to prosecutors she was allowed
to stay in a halfway house but was
removed after she tried to cheat a drug
test
she was moved to a detention center
where she was caught attempting to make
a drug
sale using a cell phone through a deal
cordova pleaded guilty to distribution
of fentanyl
in 2019 federal judge richard boulware
sentenced cordova to
10 years in prison followed by 15 years
probation
that was to me the compassion the
compassion you got 10 years
cordova requested compassionate release
the following year
the warden at her california prison
denied her request
her attorneys then made the request to
judge bulware
citing covid19 and the increased danger
of catching the virus in prison
they pointed to cordova's epilepsy
seizure disorder
asthma and obesity cordova wrote to
judge bulware saying she's clean
and earned her ged in prison in january
he tossed out the 10-year prison
sentence
reducing it to five years probation
how much do you feel like the judge let
you down the judge 100 percent
the facts of the case did not change
with covet
what changed my daughter still dead and
she's still guilty federal prosecutors
argued
reducing cordova's sentence risks
marginalizing her criminal conduct
promotes disrespect for the law
and more importantly trivializes the
overwhelming suffering of her victims
but to kerner they didn't fight hard
enough but
every time i turn around her lawyer out
lawyered them do you believe
that your office did everything you
could
to keep her in prison i can only imagine
the grief that the victim's family
is going through the frustration
with the justice system we argued
against
strongly and we put our arguments
forward as best as we could u.s attorney
nicholas trutanich says his office is
appealing the decision
we disagree with it but we do so
respectfully kerner insists her goal
isn't revenge she says she just wants
justice i cannot go to my grave whenever
that may be
knowing i did not fight for my kid
i tried reaching tiana cordova but was
unable to
i also reached out to her attorneys and
did not receive a response in time for
this report
and i reached out to judge boulware a
spokeswoman said the court does not
comment on current cases